we have a pretty good pitching match up
today and starts with marco this will be
his fourth start of the year one-on-one
record 8-2-2 era and 15 in the third
seven walks 13 strikeouts for marco
[Music]
hey pops it up into the sunshine jp
crawford
fighting off those rays
[Music]
one out
not the shift on a seeger having a cut
back
and
gets to bro two outs
late in last night's game
another pop-up murphy
battling the sun a little bit and tom
murphy puts a squeeze on it we take a
look at the indeed player resume urias
in his first start of the season it was
one of the best starts he's ever made
but his last two starts he's given up 16
hits
here's his 02
back-to-back breaking balls to start his
day with a strikeout here's kyle lewis's
first at-bat of the 20-21 season here's
the next offer on the way that fastball
is up high
basketball at 94 football four so kyle
lewis with a one-out walk and he's on at
first base right away
on an 0-2
lifts a fly ball to center
routine for taylor
seeger is out number two
dodgers not having long losing streaks
is that starting rotation somebody's
going to run into a win
got him swinging a couple of strikeouts
and he scored his first shining for
julio urias
three pitches all strikes
how about three different pitches for
strikes from marco
[Music]
marcos 2-2
[Applause]
weak ground ball jp charging no bare
hand needed how about right out of the
leather crawford gloves it shovels it
out of his glove right to evan white in
time to get mckinstry and that will
retire the side couple of nice plays by
j.p crawford number one for him so far
this year
slurve gets a swing and a miss in his
third k already
playoff pitch
perfectly placed right three
they're playing darts bullseye
a taylor who saw six pitches open the
game before popping out comes up here
with runners at first and third and one
away
line oh he does it again
he does it again
dylan moore
wow
what a play example of one away this is
right on the button a step and a dive
full extension right in the webbing
right at the end of the webbing
so a couple of great plays from dillon
last night at third base and tonight
or this afternoon i thought this was up
the middle for sure what a great play
marco's excited about it why not done
more than just remember to bring his
glove he's used it to make a couple
sparkling key defensive plays seeger
goes the other way and brings home the
first run
with two gone here in the third he
attacks the first pitch and drives home
aj pollock
dodgers won mariners nothing
street thought that he'd gotten
strike three
eventually he does get him
and his fourth one on his slurve his
fifth overall
crawford got to see four fast balls in a
row before that slurve batters are
swinging
and a swing and a miss strike three
the sixth for urias two up and two down
in the fourth the off-speed pitches have
been very good today and especially the
slurve not exactly slider spin not
exactly curveball spin
gonzalez is doing jamie moyer julio's
doing randy johnson
and the one two
all right there called strike three 97
mile an hour pitch a check swing foul
ball but julio now with seven strikeouts
he better be good
and he was the 2-2
swinging a miss strike three to change
up then a strikeout number five for
marco gonzalez and that's it for the
dodgers in the top of the fifth marco
has retired the last seven in a row
him looking
his eighth strikeout his third in a row
one going in the fifth
you know you're locked in when you're
getting this many strikeouts and you're
doing with a whole bunch of different
pitches
he got him with a fastball and he's
matched his career high with nine
strikeouts
he hasn't tried fastball low and away
tried to change up blown away he tried
to break the ball down and he starts the
fast ball in
what got him looking his 10th strike out
of the game folks we got a big time
pitching duel here today julio orios
marco gonzalez one nothing dodgers
marco's retired the last 10 men that
he's faced
gets a call on the outside corner
11 in a row retired by marco gonzalez
marco trying to dispose of mckinstry and
give
mariners a chance to
take the lead here in the home seventh
to get seeger white and murphy coming up
marco
into that walking wind up the pitch slow
breaking ball swung on and hit right up
the middle jp crawford waiting for it
makes the catch 13 consecutive hitters
retired by marco gonzalez duel in the
sun here in seattle
one gone seventh inning one nothing game
o2 pitch and another strikeout with a
huge slurve
his 11th k two up two down the hitter is
tom murphy
golf's one
deep to left
is there and the inning is over
13 in a row set down
by julio unis who is continuing to go
strong through seven innings be a
completely different headline if the
dodger offense only ends up with one run
and they would lose this game
did he go
he did strike three two gone
as soon as he starts his movement just
take off and if he throws to first just
keep running
there he goes
and he throws to first wild and rio's
fortunate just to put a glove on it that
amour is in his second yeah so you pick
your spot right there and that's why you
continue to run
deep breath
1-1 crawford
cracks his back sprawling play and from
his knees throws him out
victor gonzalez picks up right where
julio left off justin turner getting
this run in from third would be huge
there are not too many guys in the
league you'd rather have up in this
situation right now
in play seeger coming home with it
murphy tag got it
for the ninth inning against the top of
the seattle order it's kenley janssen
oh 95 and he went around two gone
95 like a frisbee
and the one-two pitch
he stuck him out how about a slider to
finish
dodgers won mariners nothing